this program is brought to you by Emory
University welcome to Emory College of
Arts and Sciences I'm Dean Jason Bryan
and I'm here this morning to talk to you
about an advising program that we offer
called pace pace here at Emory College
of Arts and Sciences stands for pre
major advising connections at Emory this
is the primary advising system for you
as you arrive and will be your advising
system until you declare your major you
will also be enrolling in a course
called pace 101 and you'll be receiving
one credit hour this is a comprehensive
advising system designed to acclimate
you to campus help you choose courses
and set you on your way to declaring
your major there are three main
components to this course summer modules
that you will complete on this
blackboard site educational sessions
that you will attend throughout the year
and scheduled meetings with advisors
approximately every two weeks in the
summer a new unit consisting of brief
presentations and assessments will be
added on blackboard as part of pace 101
you will also attend a small number of
standard sessions throughout your first
year which will further expose you to
many valuable resources at Emory
detailed information about these
components of pace 101 is provided in
the course syllabus which will be
available on this blackboard site prior
to your arrival at Emory you will be
matched with one faculty advisor and one
peer advisor who will help you with
class enrollment academic and Career
Planning and acclimation to college life
you will meet with your faculty advisor
several times throughout the year during
important academic periods including
orientation and midterm in addition to
these scheduled appointments your peer
leader will also be checking in on you
periodically to make sure things are
going smoothly for you academically you
can also feel free to schedule an
appointment with your academic advisor
at any time emphasizing relationships
and discovery pace offers valuable
resources and comprehensive support for
first-year students at Emory and we
encourage you to take full
vantage of all that this specialized
program has to offer the preceding
program is copyrighted by Emory
University